gracias por acompañarnos a esta nueva
emisión de reporteros comenzamos un mes
después de la devastadora exclusión en
el puerto de beirut que dejó la ciudad
semidestruida nuestros reporteros
hablaron con un grupo de jóvenes para
conocer cómo esta situación sumada a una
crisis múltiple social política y
económica que traía al país ha afectado
su cotidianidad su futuro y sus
esperanzas decisiones que han
desembocado incluso en un éxodo de unos
50 mil jóvenes en los últimos meses ante
la falta de ayuda del estado y
desmotivados por lo que han vivido desde
octubre de 2019 cuando el descontento
generalizado por una crisis dentro de
otra crisis los llevo a las calles a
protestar por el desempleo la corrupción
la mala gestión gubernamental la
devaluación de la moneda local y el
aumento del costo de vida esto nos
contaron
[Música]
es la primera vez que regreso aquí es tu
ex
todo está destruido
beirut barrio de mar mijhail dos semanas
después de la explosión desde hace años
negro había sido barman aquí toda su
vida se concentraba en estas calles
símbolos legendarios de noches locas en
la capital libanesa
vuelvo a ver todos esos lugares donde
trabajé
ahí es donde me tomo unas copas con mis
amigos todo está destruido
[Música]
y no es rebelde mucho
enero quedó herido durante la explosión
muchos de sus amigos desaparecieron
cerrado
la vendedora del barrio sigue ahí
si llego de armenia hace mucho tiempo es
la guardiana de los días y de la noche
en el barrio una madre para la juventud
fiestera buenos días
durante la explosión si perdí sangre
durante más de 4 horas
necesito todavía unos 40 días para sanar
normalizarnos
pero no fue capaz de darle la noticia
no quería partir del corazón es tan
adorable
terminará por enterarse que decidí irme
del país
dejar atrás todo lo conocido irse a
rehacer su vida
un salto hacia lo desconocido lejos de
sus calles lejos de su memoria
por su parte journal decidió quedarse
vamos por aquí
al igual que muchos voluntarios en
beirut y ante la ausencia total de apoyo
por parte del estado la joven de 26 años
va de puerta en puerta para ayudar a las
víctimas de la catástrofe buenos días
necesita ayuda con sus muebles o con
algo más este sofá está roto como puede
ver en realidad un poco como todo lo que
hay en mi casa vive sola aquí
si sólo estoy yo haciendo una pausa en
medio del caos de beirut
cossette también se toma el tiempo de
hacer memoria
pero para hay una la emergencia el
líbano no se detiene ahí lo sabe a la
perfección aquí la crisis es múltiple
quieres mortadela estaba bien llévame a
la tienda en las calles de beirut
cientos de niños sirios sobreviven
pidiendo limosna desde enero de 2020 y
tras la caída de la libra libanesa la
comida se volvió inasequible bueno listo
cuánto es son 29 mil verdad sí está bien
y en total 31 mil libras y la mortadela
12 mil 12.000 es realmente caro
la generosidad de yuna es famosa en el
barrio
rápidamente se une a otros niños sirios
te doy una botella de agua y nada más
hay personas allá que también tienen
hambre están en la calle y no tienen a
su familia me oyes cuando te hablo
escúchame mira están sentados solos allá
sé útil voy a darles agua ve estas
mujeres de kenia acampan delante de su
consulado desde hace varios días no
tienen más que una opción irse del país
cueste lo que cueste 500 mil empleadas
domésticas extranjeras viven en líbano
son escogidas por catálogo actualmente
decenas de miles de ellas ya no reciben
un salario le pedimos al gobierno de
kenia que prohíba la entrada de los
kenianos a liván sufrimos siendo
empleadas domésticas y sufrimos a causa
de nuestro consulado los problemas que
ya teníamos desde hace mucho tiempo se
sumaron a la catástrofe de la explosión
todos aquí lo sabemos
una diagonal de la miseria en líbano una
crisis dentro de la crisis sin ninguna
esperanza
para mohamed la conclusión es la misma
el líbano está atrapado en una espiral
que nada parece poder detener mohamed
nació en una familia chiquita muy
antigua y respetada en líbano nos lleva
a su casa en el gran sur chiíta la
región está controlada por hezbollah un
estado dentro del estado bajo las
órdenes de teherán
mohamed sabe que criticar abiertamente
el autoproclamado partido de dios es un
gran riesgo
los tipos no hacen nada dejan a la gente
en la pobreza para poder manipularlo es
mejor yo en realidad ya no me considero
como un hijo del líbano sur-norte este
no esté para mí líbano simplemente es
pero ellos lo ven así no lo creo
en la miseria solo miseria eres un hijo
del sur asegúrate que el sur se levante
marche y avance que no se queda anclado
en el pasado todavía estamos hablando de
las guerras que se acabaron hace 20 o 25
años hay que ver hacia adelante hacia el
futuro pues mira al frente ahí está uno
de los únicos hoteles de la región
serra cabo de dos meses
quién va a venir a hacer turismo aquí
nadie no dan ganas da la impresión de
que estamos en estado de alerta todo el
año
baja tu cámara porque los tipos están
ahí la bandera que está a su carro
el sur de líbano es una de las zonas más
pobres y más cerradas del país
este es el castillo de beaufort
escenario y memorial de las batallas
entre cruzados y califas árabes
ahora sus murallas dominan otra línea de
frente israel
de hecho un helicóptero israelí acaba de
entrar a líbano
es increíble violar el espacio aéreo de
las personas así con plena impunidad
tranquilos la vida es bella
para tener fuerzas si en algún momento
tenemos que enfrentar al enemigo tenemos
al menos que poder alimentarnos qué
guerra vas a pelear si tienes hambre eso
es lo que no entienden nos siguen
hablando de la guerra y de la
resistencia cómo vas a ir a la guerra si
tienes el estómago vacío
la madre de mohamed vive en nabatiyé es
uno de los territorios históricos de
hezbollah
[Música]
su casa estuvo ocupada durante más de 15
años por el ejército israelí
mohamed ha sido herido dos veces este
año ha hecho parte desde el comienzo de
la taula el levantamiento social y pro
democrático libanés de octubre de 2019
su madre está preocupada
voy a decirles a las hay una sola madre
la madre libanesa que se alegra cuando
su hijo se va de líbano y cuando su hijo
se aleja de ella viaja
ella piensa con alegría encontró algo en
otra parte
creo que es la única madre así en el
mundo
no sé si hay una madre a la que le
gustaría que su hijo se aleje de ella
pero para mohamed irse no es una opción
[Música]
el combate debe llevarse a cabo aquí en
líbano
[Música]
y líbano
yuna también ha participado en todas las
manifestaciones desde el principio de la
revolución
y ella lo sabe el movimiento de protesta
está en un momento crucial
[Música]
desde octubre
yo pienso que somos una minoría de
jóvenes a políticos sentimos que hay
muchos partidos políticos que se
apropiaron de la revolución
entonces automáticamente ya no siento
realmente ganas de hacer parte de eso
como no sé si sea algo bueno
se pasean con sus
beirut
año zero
una ciudad desierta
confinada
[Música]
y barrios enteros en duelo
una cotidianidad que se vuelve imposible
enero el antiguo barman y sara su
compañera se preparan para irse de su
apartamento en el este de beirut
[Música]
es una aventura despertarse en beirut
cada día cada mañana
porque hay que poder anticipar lo que
pasa en la ciudad un día es una
manifestación al día siguiente son
crímenes sino una pelea en medio de la
calle
pronto negro se va para armenia
el país de sus orígenes un país que no
conoce pero del cual espera obtener la
nacionalidad por su parte sara se queda
en beirut
el sueño de ambos reunirse un día en
francia nos dimos cuenta que es
realmente difícil proyectarse hacia el
futuro tenemos que hacer planes a largo
plazo imaginar nuestra vida es realmente
imposible si empezar algo en el
extranjero para nuestro futuro para
nosotros
es mejor sacrificar un año o dos ahora
que sacrificar diez o quince años sin
estar seguros que el país nos autorizara
a construir cualquier cosa si lo
queremos
más de 50.000 jóvenes libaneses ya se
han ido del país en los últimos meses un
éxodo brutalmente agravado por la crisis
económica y la explosión del 4 de agosto
en beirut
unas luces
la electricidad regresa
por aquí y por allá
pero en el mar mi hija en el barrio
mártir de los bares y de la fiesta
capitalina es la sombra de lo que fue
es ahí en esas calles donde mohamed
dinero se volvieron amigos hace varios
años
estamos cansados de morir y de renacer
sólo queremos vivir estamos cansados de
morir y renacer las personas dicen que
virus es como un fénix estamos cansados
de ser un fénix simplemente queremos
vivir la mitad de nosotros se va a ir la
otra mitad va a luchar
yo lo veo así es tal vez un combate sin
esperanza pero vale la pena
vale la pena luchar valía la pena luchar
tú crees sí
no puedo culpar t por decir eso tal vez
hace un año me hubiera molestado contigo
por abandonar pero ahora no puedo
hacerlo después de todo lo que pasó
hasta ahora si la voluntad de luchar que
tuvimos en algún momento dv esa voluntad
para mí se fue
mirando los que se quedan para luchar se
están haciendo masacrar a sí y son
tratados como animales a los animales
los tratan mejor que es
en parar
[Música]
para mohamed enero hoy una
todos hacen parte de la revolución de
octubre de 2019
es el levantamiento popular inédito para
transformar líbano
los meses pasan y el país se hunde el
poder político es indiferente y la
juventud del país está cansada
recuerde que puede repetir esta emisión
en nuestra página web más 24 punto com
para ver este y las anteriores emisiones
nos vemos la próxima semana
[Música]